[Música]
son 87 meses y sus seres queridos los
familiares de los 43 estudiantes de
ayotzinapa que desaparecieron en 2014
protestaron en ciudad de méxico para
exigir justicia mire nosotros como madre
pues no vamos a dejar de luchar eso sí
que le quede bien claro el gobierno
verdad que la pandemia que sea nosotros
no nos va a detener nosotros vamos a
seguir por el amor que les tenemos a
nuestros hijos y pues queremos como le
digo queremos saber la verdad siete años
después varias versiones han surgido y
la sociedad mexicana cuestiona la
incapacidad de las autoridades para
encontrar la verdad según datos de la
comisión de búsqueda desde 1964 méxico
acumula más de 95 mil personas
desaparecidas y no localizadas y de
acuerdo con la ong centro prodh e h más
de 20.000 casos se han presentado desde
que comenzó la administración del
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
el primero de diciembre de 2018 para
esta organización es la impunidad y la
violencia lo que impide mejorar la
crisis de derechos humanos que vive el
país y culpa de ello a las instituciones
el tránsito de procuradurías a fiscalías
ha sido decepcionante en los ministerios
públicos y fiscalías de donde
verdaderamente está el nudo de impunidad
en méxico vamos a concluir el 2021 con
más de 35.000 homicidios en el año lo
que indica que la violencia no ha cedido
y que se mantienen unos niveles muy
altos un informe presentado en octubre
por el centro de pensamiento y análisis
méxico evalúa indicó que el 94 por
ciento de los casos denunciados en
méxico quedan impunes y las causas
apuntan a un sistema que no cuenta con
herramientas de priorización ni
capacidades suficientes